for the last eight days muchelney has
been cut off from the world ring by
water it's an island and residents are
stranded the village is three-quarters
of a mile in this direction the only way
and of course is by boats and what we're
traveling on it's not a river it's a
road and you can see how deep the
floodwater is this car has been
completely submerged luckily there's not
fast flowing water at the moment it's
it's still so it's much makes life much
easier when it's it when it's still
there's no other way apart from being
airlifted out to get that off the island
the village is a bump on the Somerset
Levels at the top it's dry but if you
live at the bottom it's wet faster this
is basically into a downstairs small
utility room and a Alou and a shower
Nick studly was flooded this time last
year he was about to move back and order
a waters returned first it's always
devastating when it happens and I
suppose we've coped this time because we
had it happened a year ago but you've
only just finished the renovation we
honestly haven't finished the
renovations where as they affectionately
say glamping at the moment so we were in
the process of finishing at all process
of about to move back in kind of
permanently finishing it off and then
this and then this so it was you know
quite a shock villagers want the
environment agency to help well the
water k started coming up just before
Christmas but so far they say there's
been a leak you get very cross because
nothing's been done the rivers and the
rains haven't been dredged for 20-odd
years and nobody seems to really it's
always an excuse so we can't do we
haven't got the money well that's all
well and good but if this was another
country they'd find the money to go and
rescue them and it is a disaster there's
now a boat ferrying residents to the
mainland for supplies with more rain
forecast it's a service they'll be
relying on for the next few weeks
Alex Rossi sky news on the Somerset
Levels